Hershel is the unofficial backpack of
Colchis and a new collection of bags has
just arrived the biggest selling point
you can't rip these backs no matter how
hard I try there's no way I can rip this
thing let's try a pen I can get it to go
through but the second I take it out it
goes away even if I push it through and
then try and rip nothing it's
immediately gone there's a special
technology in here that once you kind of
rub it the hole goes away and
immediately seals itself so let's try
something sharper how about a nice you
puncture this through you can see it's
tearing it definitely made a hole but I
can't really rip it any bigger than it
is right now so maybe we need a bigger
knife
okay so it looks like a machete directly
to your Hershel teal tech bag it's going
to suck so why would we do that we just
wanted to see what would happen